um we're not in a rush or Carlito you
know actually we don't know much to get
out of the hobby
yeah ready together she's got the cake
at the other side jump yeah okay fast
but I thought we were not much yeah but
we're not trying to save anyone we're
just gonna get out of here okay we're
gonna get to the others and get
somebody's side you know that she could
die if I [ __ ] up that right yeah I'm
dying
it's hotter if you go fast
I don't think we're in a rush but well
okay to you away big I don't think it's
actually far for her size it's very nice
she just felt it my picture here I screw
every one of its climbing ones every
single one next one was circled
I feel like triangles always burst on
top one yeah it is it's two different
legs so the teacher's name yeah which
way but whatever way this is the high
launch I can't like Josh just died and
you go get by his [ __ ] sister it's
really sad so I guess
could be joined or coming yet that's a
better point don't just vanish
I wonder if we killed Josh because he
went through the danger door do we have
to go back yeah we have to go see one I
have to get some water this is cold
water yeah so she got a heart
well I you you are so concerned
cleanliness you mom oh nice to meet you
it was her time damn it I'm thinking
that my choice to go through that door
rather than to go around so I'll kill
Joffrey concern wasn't the butterfly
effect that came up when I happened
that's it yeah I'm not even I've seen
here I just want to get there safe -
done I don't move for making sense they
are learning centered on here but I knew
think josh is gonna die narrator I feel
like our home is dead okay okay
you okay Sammy okay all right you're
fine
[ __ ] he popular
this might be the Lord human no I was
the launch way yeah we're going right
way that's so much way I dress out that
creepy [ __ ] up saying running she
doesn't notice any still just she when
yes she does
she's pretty great McCullen intelligent
wasn't but I think she's one of the
smallest that could be tarnish like she
is very grateful
Sam Sann we already lost one tonight
how did he get so Earth's impossible
window to break it okay
no I can just get in break stuff
we saw that targets at the bottom watch
that means it's gonna get out ejected by
those well yeah
okay damn stairs sure light switches are
not good they had to be a lot of juice
in that I think the others are in the
basement might be someone I've done that
does that mean more people gonna die
does that mean that that hey anything
could have been quits I hope that wasn't
Chris his partner did look slightly like
it's Parker but I mean if it was surely
there's a core purpose apartments in the
I'm not sure I think it's still a Parker
but I feel like if it was Chris they
would have been more blatant about it
they would have they would have been
like oh [ __ ] Chris yeah that would have
been cool meant it's true and they
didn't make an ornament I think that was
the flexural guy yeah
old flame thrower dude isn't gonna call
today the flames room dude
so you don't like these Emily I'm saying
together enjoy everything either I want
to keep them all together
but the appliance postulate what are you
guys doing standing there oh that's
right
that's where explosion comes from
you know that that that that turnover
thumb mark in the what their kids in
like he's like we're not going and he's
like no matter what he's already putting
it all together plus up
because I thought they all gonna die yes
people who supply someone everyone dies
Jojo
oh my god
alright guys super fandom everyone say
my absolutely if she if she doesn't
switch then you would point out right
anyway don't you [ __ ] it's two of
them out
and they're slightly disappointed push
that are pretty quick next fight nice
which I thought if I went tonight I want
everyone else yes get out get the [ __ ]
out
all right so then whoever's lost
angry
oh so we chose which one I believe okay
whatever he wants going high to run I'm
looking mighty to that she could get out
their shoes on today pull over here and
she's gonna kill the other side around
which one fight
yeah quick
Janice footswitch
[ __ ] burger
Oh Oh an are slightly moved don't do it
yes wait and now get the [ __ ] out
Oh Sandra sorry
so I chill man
I tried that Hey I seriously goes trying
to move I do
go through so many so when you baby your
hands or something that was that's what
killed her that's why I was I don't
[ __ ] know when you moved it wasn't me
living how did I get me wet like it's
gonna do and then that that moved to be
slightly a little bit to the left
we both contributed to that desk for
sure mass death to 45 that was a
fucked-up death just was cuz we went
fast enough
yeah don't care about that still I don't
regret that deaf at all you know because
if I had I was trying to say maybe I
should have brought in maybe that's no
she would have fun to think and I threw
the water I don't know I could have gone
to the left I just chose to go
oh yeah is it possible thing you
couldn't tell them what hey no
he saved my life went early I watched
him die
I think that's another story but I okay
right here right in front of my nose and
he goes shopping he almost shot me he
didn't go out with a guy for however
long and you know well he had an excuse
that I should say
I'm sorry about Sam I stabbed him and I
tried to get away but I didn't know I
swear I didn't know that it was Josh
actually a mascot right here you should
make better yeah
[ __ ] me to die I still hate you so much
I wish you hadn't done it instead we
should have [ __ ] jump to safety with
Matt she was gonna live anyway you shoot
[ __ ] [ __ ] you I believe I know I was
like I know okay I know I've just been
on with me Foster don't take that all of
your shoulders buddy so that all you're
doing is almost entirely my fault
because I liked Matt hey Mike I don't
want Mike to die no feather for at the
start with the aegis Mike such a
douchebag who's supposed to like Timmons
yeah you know I thought your jock dick
but I still wanted that thing
okay the Wendigo it came out of the
darkness and it just I don't know I
heard screaming I got out of there
there's no point both was dying